dude dude
no it's all there
[Music]
one division finale week is here guys
hasn't even aired yet and i already
missed the show with the theme of this
week being checking out the last of the
theories before the finale comes out you
gotta check out
film theory's final theory video on one
division before the finale comes out
let's see what's in store today people
subscribe hit the notification bell to
get notified when our wanda vision
episode reaction
is up hopefully tomorrow morning if we
are successful like getting both parts
up it's going to be a two-part yeah you
know there's all these talks coming out
about the director saying some people
will be disappointed
paul bendy being like yeah i was
trolling still holding out hope he
wasn't just trolling
and i feel like ultimately still be
satisfied with the finale let's see
what's in store
the broken pieces of you are adding up
buttercup i have a theory
hey that's my line
hello internet welcome to film theory
youtube's embodiment of chaos magic so
here we are friends
one division is heading into its epic
episode 9 conclusion
after weeks of theorizing mostly right
some wrong we finally know what happened
we know why
we pretty much know how honestly what we
don't know is what darcy's going to
binge once there's no more
show to watch i'm very true i'm invested
so now there's nothing left except for
the final showdown where we learn the
fates of all our favorite characters
unless of course this whole show
resolves nothing and was instead of
prelude introducing us to agatha the new
vision 2.0
photon and the mini moths at which point
we're stuck waiting for resolution in
spider-man no way home in december
because that my friends is how you get
audiences to keep buying tickets to your
stuff in a post-end game world
one word cliffhangers but yeah at this
point it's pretty safe to say that
things are really going down in joysy
agnes excuse me i get the harkness
is i do want to quickly say that a
cliffhanger is an underrated movie
and b does there need to be a b
yes there will obviously be cliff
hangers but i am really hoping that this
show does have
like a solid ending to it as well as a
cliffhanger opening up the door i don't
want it to just
end only on like cliffhanger now we
gotta watch the other one they have it
feel like the story they're telling here
is finally complete that's my one thing
i'm hoping marvel doesn't do agatha
harkness
is an actual salem witch who infiltrated
the hex to steal
wanda's powers which means that wanda
did indeed create the imaginary sitcom
reality and
mind enslaved the citizens of westview
after she was driven to her
psychological
breaking point from discovering sore
desecrating visions damn what a good
show scenario suddenly orchestrated
every time i see that shot in the
channel to reactivate vision's ai brain
why else would they only start
dissecting him like five
years after he died told you that guy
was bad news and
that one had been to his weird office
confused well you're in good company
because so is wanda she didn't even know
her powers were actual
witchcraft up till this point as agatha
points out wanda is the scarlet witch
a legendary being that uses chaos magic
which in the comics means that she was
influenced at birth by the dark elder
god
oh god
honestly there are way too many times in
a row here for that word to have any
real pronunciation
oh and uh if you didn't watch through
the credits sword apparently turned
vision's empty body into a super creepy
white terminator version
so yeah that's some heavy stuff kind of
makes you wish for the simpler days when
all we were talking about was
cosmic radiation and the birth of the
multiverse but for everything that's now
been solved in the show
and everything that next week's finale
stress like ripping open the multiverse
and needing to team up with monica
photon to take down the white vision i
think that there's one massive
dangling thread that may not pay off now
may not pay off
a year from now even but will come up at
some point in phase 4. who knows maybe
it will be a post-credits scene what
dennis loses and suddenly this big
reveal happens before the final credits
roll ready for this one
what if i told you the big secret of
this show the big
final reveal was that there's a third
witch
in west view and it all comes down to
flowers
all right this is a [ __ ] weird even
division standards so lean in
i mean this is gonna be our little
secret so i'm sure by now you've noticed
that agatha and wanda's magic slash
power slash telica whatsits are color
coded when wanda does her finger waggy
zappy stuff it's always shades of red
well agatha is clearly big into purple
that's also the color of those energy
vines that we saw in episode seven's
post credit scene and the color of
all the flowers in front of her house
well it's easy to overlook but agatha
isn't the
only person with a green thumb here in
west view in the same episode where
agatha's true identity is revealed and
we get a good look at her plants we
also see wanda's garden and you guessed
it the maximoff's roses grow red but
wait a second roses come up once before
like
way back when the show was black and
white come to think of it the perfect
place to hide a color clue in plain
sight
oh my goodness cody can't be as bad as
you say her roses so it is dotty that's
what
but when this whole series began we were
introduced to dottie jones
a character who gets a big deal made out
of her and an even
bigger deal made out of her flowers
dottie is the key to
everything in this town
[Laughter]
she's set up to be a major antagonist
wanda i've heard things about you
that's so true but i assure you i don't
mean anyone
any harm i don't believe you
i gotta say i'm already loving this
because people were constantly
theorizing about dottie
but in the last few episodes no one's
been bringing her up no and she has
appeared in like
little reverse shots from like across
the street and especially after that
second episode people were like oh is
she
a big villain is she something more to
the story and so bringing it back around
and then the way this is being edited
you're like that's right
yes and of all the people in west view
she's one of the more recognizable
character actors they've cast and i have
to imagine that would be for a reason
yeah oh and especially with agatho
knowing who she is now and saying she's
the key to everything
well and also too i mean donnie seemed a
little bit too uh comfortable after that
whole blood incident too
she even gets the show's first
appearance of that creepy line about
children
all of this it's for the children
so god damn for the children but then
nothing she disappears for the rest of
the show daddy was
apparently just a red herring a false
lead a chekhov's gun left for god
through the table that's what i thought
until episode seven you see right in the
middle of what we now know in hindsight
as a big confrontation between all of
our super powered female main characters
we get a cutaway to dottie jones
and her now colorized bright yellow
rose oh dude you do it's live
the clues in the room could there be
some hidden matches i feel like i fall
for this easter egg [ __ ] too much
everything is compelling but it's
pitched the right way with purple powers
and red flowers yield an
angry confused redheaded witch with
scarlet powers it stands to reason that
yellow flowers could link up with a
blonde headed witch with yellow power
you know it but that's exactly what
you'll find in the library of marvel
comics characters why
a blonde superhero sorceress whose magic
energy signature
is usually yellow
just like dottie theorists let me
introduce you to which number three in
west view
arcana jones and if those similarities
weren't convincing enough they both
even have husbands named phil
oh and uh one other thing arcana isn't
just from the marvel universe she comes
from the marvel
multiverse so with her potentially being
important so let's talk a bit more about
her arcana wasn't me
am i getting way too salty early on i
feel like it's all there
i feel like right there it's all there i
understand your apprehension but no
it feels like it's all there of squadron
supreme a whole team of characters who
are parodies of justice league members
and who live on an alternate reality
earth that basically exists for marvel
writers to dunk on their competitors at
dc
there has been a bunch of different
versions and reboots of the squadron
over the years but what's interesting
about arkana maybe popping back
up here in the mcu is that they're also
getting a massive new push in the comics
you see marvel just recently revealed
that their big summer events series will
and uh stummy if you've heard this one
zap the universe into an
alternate timeline where core heroes
never got their origins
and the avengers never formed in other
words arkana and the rest of our
squadron supreme are doing a sort of
what-if storyline where all the usual
suspects are decommissioned and this
group of randos are now the superheroes
on earth because no one else is there to
get the job done now
you know what you're thinking
superheroes blinked away into an
alternate timeline you're gonna tell me
this is another wanda thing right
no of course not don't be ridiculous i
mean how predictable do you think these
get right
jeez guys give me some slack wasn't
wanda it was her dad magneto
anyway you see in the comics it was
really the result of combining the
subconscious minds of magneto and
charles xavier into a single entity
basically professor x and his best
friend of me made a mind baby named
onslaught and it broke the marvel
universe into different lunch periods
for a few months
so is that what one division is building
up to absolutely not
but maybe something similar if in fact
marvel is suddenly having squadron
supreme members like arkana of all
characters pop their heads out
consider this what if we've all been
thinking about this backwards almost
everyone who's theorized about wanda's
future role in the mcu myself included
has focused on her upcoming role in
multiverse of madness as this indicator
that she'll be involved in making the
marvel cinematic universe bigger and
crazier maybe by bringing in the x-men
changing powers around expanding genres
whatever but from what we've seen of her
actions and her state of mind throughout
one division bigger worlds are the
opposite of what she's looking for
one division has been all about how this
would-be scarlet witch has retreated
from the ideas of friendship and
community and found family
even reality itself she is living in her
own head
she is living inside of nostalgia
literally building walls and safe spaces
in order to protect herself
the show is clearly demonstrating that
this is unhealthy and self-destructive
but in the bigger picture she's
also fundamentally turned against the
foundations of the mcu's basic
philosophy
i don't know if you've noticed this but
each and every one of these films has
reinforced the idea of being a team
player
sacrificing for the greater good forming
found families
crossing and even ultimately eliminating
the concept of
borders and separations everything being
connected is not only marvel studios
strategy and brand
it's also their philosophical ideology
but as it concerns poor mrs maximoff
over in west view if she loses her
family again it'll push
wanda to go full onslaught and blast the
mcu into fragments
let's just take a moment to appreciate
wandavision again really quick
because that is exactly why this show's
so cool because it's not a superhero
show
every time superhero thing happens
you're like oh that's right
psychological witchcraft supernatural
series drama it's so damn good i love it
so much
usually trapping individual franchises
in worlds where avengers and guardians
never teamed up
or worlds where shield never unfroze
steve rogers or
more likely based on the upcoming movie
slate worlds where
thor is suddenly jane foster as
confirmed by the early plot of thor
love and thunder tony stark never helped
upgrade peter parker where he's left to
fend for himself alongside other famous
spider people from the past
struggling to find his way home they've
already practically
confirmed that wanda can absolutely do
this even before we knew about the
apparently limitless power of the chaos
magic
this appears most clearly in episode
seven's fake commercial act break for
the antidepressant medication
nexus a unique antidepressant that works
to anchor you back to your reach
or the reality of your choice at this
point in the series all the other
commercial breaks have been explained
the toaster was tony stark's bomb like
we predicted the hydra soap was the mine
stone
also kind of like we predicted the shark
eating yo magic yogurt
looking to consume wanda's powers
leaving her an empty dried out husk the
only one left unexplained is that final
nexus commercial
and that's because it's not looking
backwards but rather
is the only one looking ahead at once
specifically nexus is a clear reference
to the comics's nexus of all realities
which acts as a hub between the
different regions of the multiverse and
also to nexus beings superhumans that
are powerful enough to manipulate the
order and shape of those realities
i'll give you one guess as to who's a
nexus being wanda guess who made that
distinction a group of cosmic
bureaucrats named the time
variance authority don't worry it
shouldn't yes
get used to hearing the name they're the
guys who are almost certainly giving
orders to the god of mischief
of course could eventually be
triumphantly recombined in ways that
would make reintroducing mutants in
humans x-men deadpool everyone from
netflix minus iron fist and all manner
of reboots much much simpler
and more importantly we give phase four
a chance to
reaffirm how important all that family
and connection stuff is to the mcu
and how lost all the characters were
without it while also doing a bunch of
meta satirical dunking on certain
other superhero franchises that always
go the solo superhero route huh which
obscure marvel team suddenly seems to be
all over the place again
it was arcana all along but
hey that's just a theory a film
theory and one other thing for weeks now
fans of the series have been buzzing
about paul bettany's tease of a special
guest star that's yet to appear on the
show about which he'd only say that
they're a performer that he's really
wanted to work with and has never had
the chance to before the guesses on this
have encompassed basically every actor
who has ever played a superhero but has
never shared a scene with vision
from patrick stewart as professor x to
hugh jackman
maybe it is paul because we don't know
who the character is or
if it'll be a marvel character at all
but we do have ourselves a theory about
who that mystery
actor will be when they show up none
other than the disney legend
dick van dyke you see episode 8 revealed
that the reason
wanda's magic mental breakdown happy
place looks like ancient american
sitcoms is that like a lot of real-life
immigrants of her generation she learned
it's going to be intense scenes with
dickman
dick van dyke what would be the intense
scenes
i don't know it can't fight history
but i saw him
in part watching classic american tv
shows and formed a powerful nostalgic
connection to their idealized version of
american suburbia and while we saw
dvds or clips from almost every series
wand division has made references to
only one was explicitly highlighted and
named as
wanda's absolute favorite the dick van
dyke show
which not only formed the point of
reference for wandavision's first
episode the series creators actually
brought in the still very much alive 95
year old comedy star
as a consultant to help them get their
classic tv feel
just right so yeah i'm calling my shot
with this one the big final guest
appearance of the show
will be dick van dyke as far as who
they're gonna have him play don't really
know think he can pull off a submariner
speedo
one man i i want it look i'm all for
everything else you said
but i'm drawing the line i don't think
it's stick fantastic
cameo but i don't think that's what he
was referring to
that just sounds a little too much i
mean
especially after everything paul bettany
would say but everything about dottie
especially with like all the clues about
agatha harkness and yeah it ended up
being adequate the hardness
a lot of the more apparent comic
references that seem to be coming true
it just seems likely that it would be
dotty um
from the comics that he's pulling from
here so yeah i believe that one plus
what does that open us up to like other
marvel movies where they'll be take it
directly right
i mean it would all right guys well
what'd you guys think of this this is a
wonderful another
solidly executed hilarious perfectly
scripted perfectly edited video from
film theory push them over the line to a
billion subscribers keep a lookout for
our one division reaction love this one
subscribe click the notification bell
hit that like button
check out our other one division videos
last but not least
i got a new shirt nelson and murdock
attorney at law
another person who wears red who is also
losing some vision
oh perfect this comes from maria hammond
maria sent us over several shirts and
this is the most recent one that she
sent us all right next marvel video i
gotta be wearing
this t-shirt thank you so much maria i
love it
fits wonderfully gotta kind of wash it
so it straightens out a little bit
but right now it's perfect you've been
such a sweetheart to both
john and i um i love chatting with you
you're such an
incredible support to us in more ways
than one you rock thank you so much for
every single thing you've ever given us
and thank you mainly for your kindness
and for
lending us your heart in so many ways